I just got off the phone with the doj
they've arrested over 75 I think it's
his men his operation is decimated
did they find figus not yet but they're
confident they will and when they do
detective pimento can come home hello
Jake Peralta this is Jimmy figgis oh uh
hey dog you and Ray Holt took down my
operation
now I'm gonna kill you both later dog
uh Captain Holt
blue skies smiling at me
nothing but blue skies do I see good
morning Greg
good morning Larry
birds all day long frozen cops yes I
mean oh no what a bummer of the police
but still maybe a lesson for all of us
the crime doesn't pay we go on the front
door we use the wedge formation on my
command
we were going very fast I know I'm still
pretty coked up let's do this did I nine
you are not a police officer you're not
part of this mission right okay well I'm
just gonna go in this Bank cash check
whatever happens happens am I right
let's do this
great work boys We're Cops
wait where's Captain Holt who's Captain
Hook I don't know Captain Holt what and
why payday put down your weapons
help what is happening we're at the
wrong Bank
I'm crashing we're NYPD officers this is
an undercover operation that's a lie
Peralta you're the golden gang we've
been on to you for weeks but we finally
got you Hawkins how did how did you get
over there who were they you tell me
yeah your crew the goddess Jake
it's over I've never seen them
but what is going on good job everyone
we finally got the golden gang
I can't believe
hey girlfriend Jake Maura told me who
Vegas has working for him in the FBI
yeah I already know who he is because I
just caught him special agent Ryan
Whelan also I did one full pull-up I'm
gonna be so Buff when you get back cool
babe did you get the other guy what
other guy someone named Bob Anderson
Bob
oh my God Amy I have to go
Bob is working for figus what he must
have been the one who deleted all those
digital files and he tried to have wheel
and killed but he helped us with the
heist and there was nothing about him in
the paper file yeah because that wasn't
the real file I just need to put my
return address on it
yeah
there you go oh thank you
we have to call halt
come on Captain pick up pick up
don't answer that Raymond
and now I'm going to have to kill you
oh Bob I planned everything starting
with scully's bracelet it had to be the
prize because I have prepared the
greatest reveal in Heist history allow
me to introduce you to
other Scully hi I'm Merle noon's twin
brother why is Scully never mentioned he
had a twin before because no one talks
about their siblings with co-workers
I've told you about my brother Lauren
nope and I don't want to learn about him
and I already forgot his name now let's
go it's time to Heist Court more lube
and help me yank
oh you know that fun braggy recap we do
at the end of each win can we leave this
burnout yes we'll make up a cooler thing
but for now we lube and yank rub your
legs around them to Anchor yourself yep
here we go Norm
[Music]
Norm what they're so happy your friend
invited me I told you what happened if I
ever saw you again Earl what is going on
what am I looking at Scotty has a twin
brother named Earl Jake brought him here
to trick you thank you for the ride
Terence for the final heist we will all
be competing for this is that my medal
of valor from the very first ice it is
modeled after it yes but this is far
more meaningful I got mine for saving
the life of Maya Angelou boring this one
says grand champion on it and it's made
out of gold a non-gold alloy that should
not be handled by women who are pregnant
or nursing yours is garbage and this
golden vessel is from the precinct's old
pneumatic tube system it's been
outfitted with A Time release lock set
for midnight Whoever has the medal at
that time will be the winner
now let the last day Heist begin it's an
amazing plan babe thank you very much
and everyone's going to be so shocked
when they find out the big surprise
that I'm leaving the 99
what did you just say
[Music]
hello Jacob Hames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and I both
know the belt never left the precinct I
don't know that nobody knows that I kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key and
then it hit me they didn't they swapped
the safe one of the handmaids I'm
assuming fake Charles took my safe and
then of Amy deposited a lookalike
where did you give fake Charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of Financial Freedom
I invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay so
while we all tried to figure out who had
the real key fake Charles broke into the
safe removed the tracker and led Terry
and the whole squad on a wild goose
chase my only question is which box is
the belt in wow good luck figuring it
out because the clock is Tick Tick
tocking it's that one no the dust
pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors
you see Jake I'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you just plain
boring again weird take on a very loving
relationship and it's midnight so I
guess I'm an amazing human slash genius
yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that there built why oh no what does
it say
Amy Santiago will you marry me
surprise
hey you guys got a second can you talk
to you about something whatever it is
get away Rosie you're gonna want to see
this question what is the number one
problem with the coronavirus Mass deaf
economic collapse the way the disease is
exposed to systemic Injustice at the
core of American life well yes obviously
those but after that it's how to
high-five your friends while staying six
feet apart right now the world can stop
there worrying because we have created
the covid five with this machine you can
execute any high five your heart desires
there's the classic slip me some skin
sprinkle me sprinkle me sprinkle
sprinkle sprinkle the Vulcan scissor
that's a bad one yeah and of course the
Need for Speed
wow that was impressively stupid I know
right so what was it you wanted to tell
me just wanted to say goodbye I turn in
my resignation I quit the force
dude that was by far the best five
you're you're quitting I've just
received the email about whether I've
gotten the job as commissioner
well from the look on my face I'm sure
you can guess what it says
no we have no idea at all just tell us
you monster really no one noticed the
slight tension in my labial commissioner
my lips I'm smiling wait you're smiling
wait we're allowed to say labia again
wait you got it I got it
maybe a commissioner Raymond Holt labia
you got to stop right now Hitchcock we
need to celebrate we need music
for the wedding
talk about that it was gonna be a
surprise our first dance was going to be
in a Tootsie Roll oh
I want to thank you all what an
incredible moment 30 years of struggle
and sacrifice but it was worth it
because I finally get to read the 10
words I've longed to hear Raymond Holt
you are not the oops I misread the email
didn't say that not
so I will not
be the new commissioner y'all ready for
this
[Music]
why is no one else dancing did I miss
something feels like I missed something
I'm just gonna keep going until someone
tells me all right commissioner still
not used to hearing that of course I'm
only acting commissioner until they
choose someone permanent might well be
you after all you brought down John
Kelly I wonder what he's doing now he's
got a much higher paying job in the
private sector yes the world is horrible
but then again sometimes it surprises
you this whole time I thought you were
up to something but really you just
wanted what was right for the NYPD I did
but also I was up to something
[Music]
that's life
that's what all the people say
you're riding high in April shot down in
May
but I know I'm Gonna Change That Tune